GOOD THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. UH DOES
NOT HAVE A QUORUM. SO UH, WE'RE
GONNA START AS A SUBCOMITTEE.
AND THE FIRST THING WE'RE GONNA
DO IS MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL. THAT'S S¼
B 1028. SENATOR ALVARADO GIL.
BEFORE YOU BEGIN. I WANT TO
REMIND MEMBERS THAT THE AUTHOR
IS TAKING AMENDMENTS HERE TODAY.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE IN YOUR
BINDERS AND HAVE BEEN SHARED
WITH YOUR STAFF. IN ADDITION,
THE ANALYSIS BEFORE YOU REFLEX
THOSE AMENDMENTS WITH THAT
CENTER, PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. UH MR CHAIRPERSON, UM AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. SENATE
BILL 1028 WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL BEVERAGES
AND, UH, BEVERAGE CONTROL TO
ISSUE UP TO 10 ADDITIONAL TYPE
47 LICENSES TO A COUNTY. AFTER
THAT COUNTY REACHES ITS LIMIT.
THE BILL ALSO GIVES LOCAL
CONTROL BY ALLOWING A COUNTY TO
DECIDE HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
LICENSES TO REQUEST FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF A B èC. TYPE 47
LICENSES ALLOW AN EATING PLACE
LIKE RESTAURANTS TO SELL BEER,
WINE AND LIQUOR FOR CONSUMPTION
ON THE PREMISES. CURRENT LAW
CAPS THE NUMBER OF THESE
LICENSES TO COUNTIES BASED ON
THEIR POPULATION RATIO OF ONE
LICENSE PER 2000 RESIDENTS.
OFTEN TIMES A GROWING COUNTY
WILL BE HINDERED BY THE LARGE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE DEMAND
FOR TYPE 47 LICENSES AND THE
SUPPLY THAT A B èC CAN PROVIDE.
ADDITIONALLY MANY RURAL COUNTIES
LIKE THE ONES THAT I REPRESENT
HAVE RELATIVELY SMALL, PERMANENT
POPULATIONS WHILE HOSTING A
LARGE TOURIST POPULATION
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. AND
FORTUNATELY, TOURISM IS NOT A
FACTOR WHEN DETERMINING THE
NUMBER OF TYPE 47 LICENSES A
COUNTY MAY RECEIVE OVER THE
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ROUTINELY PASSED BILLS THAT
ALLOW A B èC TO ISSUE
ADDITIONAL LICENSES TO SPECIFIC
COUNTIES. SENATE BILL 1028 WILL
APPLY THESE POLICIES STATEWIDE
AND ALLOW ANY COUNTY TO REQUEST
UP TO 10 ADDITIONAL TYPE 47
LICENSES TO CONCLUDE THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GROW AND FOSTER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS AUDREY LET ME TRY
THIS RAAI CH ON BEHALF OF UNAL,
ROCO AND WESTVILLE. GOOD MORNING
. GOOD MORNING CHAIR DODD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AUDREY
R. I KNOW IT'S A HARD ONE. I
REPRESENT WESTFIELD. UM, I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B
1028, WHICH IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE TO HELP YOU MOVE FORWARD
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE,
INCLUDING IMPROVEMENT AND GROWTH
OPPORTUNITIES PLANNED BY
WESTFIELD. UM, THE BILL ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT OF A B èC TO
ISSUE UP TO 10 ADDITIONAL TYPE
47 LICENSES TO A COUNTY IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR FOLLOWING ANY YEAR
IN WHICH THE COUNTY REACHES ITS
LIMIT. MANY NEW OR GROWING
BUSINESSES THAT APPLY FOR A
OFTEN MUST WAIT FOR MONTHS OR
LONGER BEFORE EVEN HAVING THE
POSSIBILITY OF SECURING A
LICENSE IF NÓ LICENSES ARE
AVAILABLE FROM THE STATE DUE TO
THE POPULATION RESTRICTIONS
BUSINESSES INTERESTED IN
OBTAINING AN A B èC LICENSE MAY
PURCHASE ONE FROM AN EXISTING
LICENSEE. FOR WHATEVER THE PRICE
THE MARKET WILL BEAR, AND THIS
HAS BEEN A MAJOR IMPEDIMENT FOR
RESTAURANTS IN OUR AREA BECAUSE
THERE ARE EITHER NÓ AVAILABLE
LICENSE TO PURCHASE OR THE
MARKET HAS DRIVEN UP THE PRICES
FOR A SECONDARY LICENSE TO OVER
$250,000 JUST FOR ONE. THIS IS
THE EXACT CHALLENGE WE'RE
CURRENTLY FACING AS WE UNDERGO
CHANGES AND IMPROVEMENTS AT THE
WESTFIELD GALLERIA IN ROSEVILLE,
WE WOULD LIKE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS EXPANSIONS AND
CONTINUE TO BRING NEW ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO OUR
MALL TO SUPPORT THE REGION. BUT
THE LACK OF AVAILABLE LIQUOR
LICENSES HAS MADE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO CONTRACT WITH NEW
RESTAURANTS WHO HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO GET A LICENSE IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO WANT TO MOVE FORWARD TO
SECURE A SPOT. UM THIS BILL
WOULD HELP SUPPORT BUSINESSES
AND ENSURE RESTAURANTS THRIVE BY
ALLOWING ADDITIONAL TYPE 47
LICENSES TO A COUNTY THAT HAS
REACHED ITS LIMIT BECAUSE THE
POPULATION LIMIT DOES NOT ALWAYS
ACCOUNT FOR LARGE TOURIST
POPULATIONS, WHICH WE HAVE AT
THE GALLERIA. UM FOR THESE
REASONS WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BEFORE WE CONTINUE. LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DOD HERE.
WILK PRESENT PRESENT. ALVARADO
GIL HERE, ALVARADO. GO HERE.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HERE. ASHBY
BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE. GLASER
JONES JONES HERE WHEN? WHEN?
HERE, OCHO PAD PENTIN. QUANTI
HERE. ROTH RUBIO. SARDO SARTO
HERE, SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. FOLLOW
CUEVAS HERE. FANTASTIC SO WE NOW
HAVE A QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH SENATOR ALVARADO.
GILLS FOR THOSE, UH, VIEWING AT
HOME. UH, IT IS SB 1028. UH,
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NATE SOLO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT
DISTILLERS ASSOCIATION, PASSER
ROBLES DISTILLERY TRAIL AND
TRAVEL PASO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON THIS AND THE
CHAIR. THIS IS ABOUT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB CREATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE? ME
TOO. STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND I THINK HE'S
YEP, I'LL GET THERE. I'LL GET
THERE. HANG ON A SECOND. HANG ON
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM? WISH
YOU TO SEE THAT NOW? COME ON UP.
ANYBODY OPPOSED? TO 1028 SORRY
ABOUT THE CONFUSION THERE. I AM
WAY TOO EXCITED TO BE OPPOSED.
SORRY. UM BUT TH THANK YOU THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. UH, MY NAME IS CARSON
BENNETT FREDERICKS. I'M THE
RESEARCH DIRECTOR AT ALCOHOL
JUSTICE. WE'RE A 501 èC THREE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN CENTER
FELL THAT ADVOCATES FOR POLICIES
THAT PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
NÓ VOTE ON S¼ B 1028 THE SORT OF
BE ALL AND END ALL WHY WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS IS THAT
RESTRICTIONS ON ALCOHOL OUTLET
DENSITY ARE A REALLY FUNDAMENTAL
PLANK IN, UH, KEEPING ALCOHOL
SAFE AND LEGAL THAT WHEN, UH, WE
FIND THAT THERE ARE TOO MANY
ALCOHOL OUTLETS IN ONE SMALL
AREA. WE FIND THAT A NUMBER OF
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS EMERGE,
INCLUDING VIOLENCE, INCLUDING
DANGEROUS DRIVING, INCLUDING
PEOPLE DRINKING IN WAYS THAT
DIRECTLY HARMS THEMSELVES. UH
AND IN FACT, UH, RESTRICTIONS ON
ALCOHOL OUTLETS ARE A POLICY
ADVANCE BY MORE OR LESS EVERY
MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH BODY,
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
HEALTH ASSOCIATION, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION. UH CHANGE
LAB SOLUTIONS BACKS THIS UP.
THIS IS KIND OF ACCEPTED
STANDARD FOR PROTECTIVE POLICY.
AND CALIFORNIA IS IN A PERIOD OF
RAPIDLY RAPIDLY ESCALATING
ALCOHOL HARM. IN 2016, THE
MORTALITY PER YEAR WAS AROUND
11,000. NOW IT'S OVER 19,000.
THAT'S SO IN IN, UH, EIGHT YEARS
WE'VE GONE UP 8000 ADDITIONAL
DEATHS PER YEAR FROM ALCOHOL. A
AND THEN, ACCORDING TO A
ANALYSIS THAT WE ACTUALLY DID
LOOKING AT, UH, BILLS PASSED IN
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT ENHANCED
THE NUMBER OF PLACES THAT PEOPLE
COULD GET ALCOHOL THERE HAVE
BEEN IN THE LAST. THERE'S BEEN
THE LAST 10 YEARS. I BELIEVE 55
OR 57, SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT
ENHANCE ACCESS EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THOSE, UH, TAKES THAT HARM UP
A LITTLE BIT, AND THAT'S HOW YOU
END UP WITH 8000. UH, SO AGAIN,
WHAT WE NEED IS A BREAK. UH WHEN
WE LOOK AT REAL NUMBERS, WE HAVE
SIMULATIONS OF DENSITY LIMITS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT FOUND THAT
REDUCING LICENSES BY ONE BAR PER
ZIP CODE WOULD REDUCE. UH, WHAT
WOULD PREVENT 290 SERIOUS
ASSAULTS PER YEAR? AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE ONE OTHER POINT,
WHICH IS THAT WHILE WE SORT OF
HAVE THIS INSTINCT TO THINK OF
THIS AS A LIQUOR STORE PROBLEM,
IT IS ACTUALLY ISN'T AND THERE'S
A LOT OF BURGEONING RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS THAT THIS IS
CONNECTED TO BOTH ON AND OFF
SALE. UH, BONA FIDE EATING PLACE
IS, UH, LIKE GOOD, AT LEAST IN
TERMS OF GENERATING MORE JOBS.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS, THEY DON'T
ALWAYS JUST RESTRICT THEMSELVES
TO OPERATING AS BONE FIGHT
EATING PLACES THEY OPERATE AS
BARS THAT DOES HAVE A HIGHER
RISK PROFILE AS WELL. UM AND
LAST WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN DURING
POST PANDEMIC THE LOCUS OF HARM
FROM OVER CONCENTRATION SHIFT
FROM BEING OFF SALE OUTLETS LIKE
LIQUOR STORE STORES TO ON SALE
OUTLETS. THIS IS A MANY FACTOR
CHANGE, UH, THAT PEOPLE ARE
STILL. EXP BUT IT DOES REALLY
LEND AGAINST THE WISDOM OF SORT
OF AN UNCAPPED, INFINITE
EXPANSION OF, UH OF ALCOHOL
LICENSES TO ANY STORE THAT IS
ALREADY AT THE LEVEL THAT A B
èC FLAGS AS KIND OF HAZARDOUS
SO AGAIN, I ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE
NÓ ONE S¼ B, 1028 AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HØI GOOD MORNING. UM MY NAME IS
RAUL VERDUGO, PROGRAM DIRECTOR
AT THE OF THE, UH FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE. THAT'S CAPA, A PROJECT
OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE. WE REPRESENT
35. YOU PUT THE MIC DOWN A
LITTLE BIT SO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
I'M SORRY. WE REPRESENT 35
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE WITH A
MISSION TO UNITE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES IN THE PREVENTION
AND REDUCTION OF ALCOHOL RELATED
HARM. WE ARE OPPOSED TO SENATE
BILL 1028 FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS THIS, UH, SYSTEM WILL
NOT RETIRE EXISTING LICENSES
WHERE LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES ARE
LIKELY TO BE OVER CONCENTRATED.
IT'S CONSIDERED AN UNDEMOCRATIC
APPROACH IN THAT IT DISEMPOWERS
COMMUNITIES WITH THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LICENSING
PROCESS, AND IT REMOVES THE
RIGHTS OF SELF DETERMINATION
THAT ANY AND ALL COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS SHOULD BE EXPECTED
TO HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NONE. I'LL TURN TO, UH,
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
GO COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR ARCHULETA.
SENATOR I GOT A QUESTION. YOU
KNOW, EACH COUNTY HAS A
DIFFERENT POPULATION IS THE I
SEE THE NUMBER OF 10 AS IT IS IT
UP TO 10, OR DOES IT ANY WAY
REFLECT THE POPULATION? AS YOU
KNOW, IN L, A COUNTY WE'VE GOT
10 MILLION PEOPLE, AND WE'VE GOT
THE OLYMPICS COMING TO L, A
COUNTY AND IN 2028. WE'VE GOT
THE, UH, HOPEFULLY THE GAMES
COMING AND ALL SORTS OF THINGS
AND, UH, EXPANDING OBVIOUSLY IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. SIZES
OF 10 MILLION PEOPLE MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT OF SENSE. BUT IN
ANOTHER COUNTY WHEN THERE'S ONLY
1 MILLION OR WHATEVER IS, UH,
HOW ARE YOU WORKING WITH THAT?
WELL, YES. SO WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
, UH, REALLY THE LACK OF EQUITY,
UH IN, UH, COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE SO COUNTIES THAT HAVE A
SMALLER POPULATION ARE STILL
HELD TO THE SAME STANDARDS IN
TERMS OF, UM, POPULATION RATIO,
SO IT DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE A VAST TOURISM THAT COMES
INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES. AND SO
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE THAT THAT LENS OF EQUITY
NOW WE KNOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAS A VERY LARGE POPULATION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. UM THIS BILL
PERHAPS WOULD NOT, UH WELL, IT
WOULD NOT HINDER, BUT IT PERHAPS
WOULD NOT HELP THEM IN A SENSE
THAT WOULD CREATE LARGER
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. BUT THIS
WOULD DO A GREAT DEAL OF AMOUNT
FOR OUR SMALLER RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THE
MAJORITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
OTHER THING THAT I WANT TO NOTE
IS THAT THAT THE 10 ADDITIONAL
LICENSES ARE UP TO 10, AND THERE
ARE STILL LOCAL CONTROL. THERE
IS STILL THAT ABILITY OF THE
LOCAL BODY THE COUNTY BODY TO
ASSESS, MAKE A VOTE AND MAKE A
ULTIMATE APPLICATION TO A B èC.
SO THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATING THAT STEP OF, UM
EXCLUDING THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES, AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING TO DO. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARITY, MR CHAIR. SO REALLY,
YOUR BILL IS ESSENTIALLY TO
MAKE, UM THE COMPETITION BETWEEN
A, YOU KNOW DIFFERENT ENTITIES
THAT POP UP IN RU. YOU KNOW,
RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE TOURIST
AREAS MAKE THEM COMPETITIVE SO
THAT THEY CAN SURVIVE. CORRECT
AND THEY'RE STILL GONNA PEOPLE
ARE STILL GOING TO GO THERE. IF
ONE'S NOT SELLING, AND ONE IS
SELLING, THEY'LL JUST GO TO THE
ONE THAT'S SELLING IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE IN IN THAT AREA FOR
THAT'S RIGHT, AND I REPRESENT
SOME OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL AREAS
IN THE STATE THAT ATTRACTS
VISITORS FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
. UM LAKE TAHOE, YOSEMITE. MONO
LAKE AND INYO AND THESE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT THRIVE WITH
TOURISM. BUT IF WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO GIVE THE LOCAL RESTAURANTS
AND THE LOCAL BUSINESS OWNERS,
UM THAT APPEAL TO THOSE TOURISTS
THAT WANT TO ENJOY A GLASS OF
WINE, FOR EXAMPLE, WITH THEIR
MEAL. UM THEN WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ATTRACT THE WORKFORCE AND
ATTRACT THAT, UM, INVESTMENT OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, SO WE WANT
A FAIR PLAYING FIELD AT THE SAME
TIME. I'M LOOKING ALSO TO
DISCOURAGE AND ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATE ILLEGAL MARKET OF
LIQUOR LICENSE SALES THAT WE'VE
SEEN ON, UM DIFFERENT SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS AND DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT PEOPLE HAVE BARTERED
WITH THESE LIQUOR LICENSES FOR
SOMETIMES HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS ABOVE THE PRICE THAT
THEY WOULD ULTIMATELY PAY
LEGALLY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OK? SO SENATOR IS A CO-AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL AND AUTHOR OF SIMILAR
BILLS IN IN IN THE PAST. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ALLOW OUR COUNTIES TO HAVE A SAY
IN WHAT BUSINESSES THEY UH, THEY
ALLOW IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION OF THIS BILL FROM
PREVIOUS BILLS. I'VE SEEN
COUNTLESS BILLS, ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT TO ISSUE ADDITIONAL
RESTAURANT LICENSES. I THINK
THIS IS A MUCH MORE EFFICIENT
SOLUTION THAT NEGATES THE NEED
FOR INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES TO HAVE
HAVE THE SPONSOR LEGISLATION
EVERY TIME THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
LICENSES. WITH THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY, COUNTIES WILL BE
ABLE TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES IN THE DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT CAN ISSUE IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES OR IF
THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO COMPLETELY
REFUSE ANY OF THE LICENSES THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES. I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF LOCAL
CONTROL, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE. OK THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON S¼? B
1028. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. UM THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
TODD. HØI DOD I WILK WILK. I
ALVARADO GILL, I ALVARADO GIL. I
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I ASHBY
BRADFORD. LASER JONES. JONES I
WHEN I OCHO I OCHO I PAD PAD I
PINO PINO, I ROTH RUBIO RUBIO. I
CIARDO SERAO I SMALL QUA I SMALL
WORD. QUAS I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THE BILL HAS 12 VOTES. WE'LL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS, AND WE'LL MOVE
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE AGENDA.
PLEASE WILK MOVES A CONSENT
CALENDAR. OK WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WILKS SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. I NEED TO READ THOSE
INTO THE RECORD. OK SO THE
MOTION ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS INCLUDES FIVE ITEM NUMBER
ONE S¼ B NINE THREE ONE FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S¼ B 978 SARTO F
ITEM NUMBER FIVE S¼ B, 958, DODD
AND FILE NUMBER SIX S¼ B 1014
DOD. DO WE HAVE A MOTION? WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WILK.
NOW, SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? DODD? I DOD I WK
WK I ALVARADO GILL. ALVARADO
GILL. I ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. I
ASHBY BRADFORD. BLAZER. JOHN
JONES. I WHEN. OCHO OCHO, I PAD
PAD I PINO. I ROTH. RUBIO RUBIO.
I SEO I SEO I SMALL CUBA SMALL
CUEVAS. I SORRY WHEN I THAT BILL
HAS 12 VOTES WILL KEEP THAT BILL
ON CALL AS WELL. WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE. B 969,
SENATOR WEINER UP AND READY TO
GO AS USUAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SIR. I JUMPED THE GUN A
LITTLE BIT. YOU WERE CALLING ME
BUT YOU WERE CALLING ME
CALENDAR. UM COLLEAGUES. UH, I'M
HERE TO PRESENT. UH, S¼ B 969.
IF UH, IF THIS BILL LOOKS
FAMILIAR, IT'S BECAUSE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS PASSED, UH, A
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL OUT THIS
TWICE BEFORE A FEW YEARS AGO.
UH, IT WAS IN A DIFFERENT BILL,
AND IT GOT STRIPPED OUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROACH. UH, LAST YEAR
, S¼ P 76 PASSED THIS COMMITTEE
AND, UH, WAS NARROWED DOWN ONLY
TO SAN FRANCISCO AND THEN EVEN
NARROWER STILL IN ASSEMBLY
APPROACH, AND SO WE'RE HERE
AGAIN, UH, WITH A GOOD BILL,
WHOSE TIME HAS COME AND
HOPEFULLY THIS TIME, WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY GET IT IN A
STRONG FORM THROUGH THE SENATE
AND TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR SO I
APPRECIATE YOU HEARING THE BILL.
UM THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY QUITE
SIMPLE. IT WILL, UM ALLOW NOT
REQUIRE ALLOW CITIES IF THEY
WANT TO DESIGNATE OUTDOOR
ENTERTAINMENT ZONES, WHICH COULD
BE PART OF THEIR DOWNTOWN AREA.
IT COULD BE A TOWN SQUARE. UH,
IT COULD BE WHATEVER THEY WANT,
UH AND IN THOSE ENTERTAINMENT
ZONES THEY'LL BE ABLE TO DEFINE
THE SCOPE AND WHAT PEOPLE CAN DO
THE HOURS. UM UH UH, THEY COULD
DO IT THREE 165 DAYS A YEAR ONLY
ON WEEKENDS ONLY ON SATURDAYS.
UH ONLY A FEW DAYS A MONTH. ONLY
SPECIAL EVENTS. UH AND WHAT IT
WILL ALLOW IS LOCAL BARS AND
RESTAURANTS TO BE ABLE TO SELL
ALCOHOL ONTO THE STREET. UM
RIGHT NOW, UH, CITIES CAN
DESIGNATE, UH, QUOTE UNQUOTE
OPEN CONTAINER ZONES. THEY HAVE
THAT ABILITY RIGHT NOW. UH
HOWEVER, UM, THOSE ARE ONLY FOR
SPECIAL EVENTS AND ONLY OUTSIDE
VENDORS CAN COME IN TO SELL. FOR
EXAMPLE, BEER, UM, THE LOCAL
RESTAURANTS AND BARS THAT ARE IN
THAT ZONE CANNOT SELL INTO THE,
UH, OPEN CONTAINER ZONE. SO YOU
CAN IMAGINE HOW FRUSTRATING IT
WOULD BE IF YOU ARE, SAY, A BAR
OR RESTAURANT OWNER AND YOU SEE
OUTSIDE THEY'RE SELLING BEER ON
THE STREET. BUT YOU CAN'T DO
THAT. THAT IS UNFAIR. UM AND SO
THIS WILL GIVE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR CITIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACTIVATE. UH, THEIR, UM,
WHETHER IT'S THEIR DOWNTOWN
AREAS OR SOMEWHERE ELSE. WE KNOW
THAT COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC.
UM A LOT OF CITIES SAN FRANCISCO
MIGHT BE IS THE MOST EXTREME
EXAMPLE BUT NOT THE ONLY ONE
WHERE DOWNTOWNS HAVE NOT COME
BACK AND CITIES WANNA TRY TO
FIND WAYS TO BRING PEOPLE TO
ACTIVATE OUTDOOR SPACE TO
SUPPORT THEIR, UH, SMALL
BUSINESSES.  N S¼ B 969 WILL
HELP THEM DO THAT, UM, ONE THING
THAT'S IN THE BILL THAT WASN'T
IN THE BILL YOU PASSED LAST YEAR
OR SOME ADDITIONAL GUARD RAILS
AND CLARIFICATIONS THAT WE PUT
IN IN THE ASSEMBLY, MAKING SURE
THAT ONLY PEOPLE 21 AND OLDER UH
, CLARIFYING THAT THE OPEN
CONTAINER ZONE OR THE
ENTERTAINMENT ZONE HAS TO SHUT
DOWN WHENEVER THE LATEST LIQUOR
LICENSE UH UH OF ANY OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND ALSO
REQUIRING CITIES TO CONSULT WITH
THEIR LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT.
TO OBTAIN FEEDBACK BEFORE
PASSING AN ORDINANCE. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
ZANE BARNES FROM THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE, WHICH IS ONE OF OUR CO
SPONSORS, AND BOB SIMPSON, A
BOARD MEMBER FOR CALIFORNIA
NIGHTLIFE ASSOCIATION AND THE
OWNER OF A OF NIGHTLIFE
ESTABLISHMENTS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, UH AND IN THE BAY
AREA SINCE 1990 GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, HONORABLE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS ZANE BARNES AND I'M, THE
CHIEF INTERGOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS OFFICER FOR THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE, WHO IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF S¼ B 969. AS WE
EMERGE FROM THE PANDEMIC BARS,
RESTAURANTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
VENUES ARE PLAYING AN OUTSIZED
ROLE IN BRINGING PEOPLE INTO
CENTRAL BUSINESS DISTRICTS.
EVENTS LIKE SAN JOSE JAZZ,
SUMMERFEST AND MUSIC IN THE PARK
ALONGSIDE OUR NIGHTLIFE HUBS IN
THE SOFA DISTRICT IN SAN PEDRO
SQUARE ARE BRINGING LIFE BACK TO
OUR URBAN CENTER. HOWEVER OUR
HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES FACE
IMMENSE CHALLENGES. IN SAN JOSE.
FOOD AND BEVERAGE SALES IN OUR
DOWNTOWN REMAIN 13% BELOW PRE
PANDEMIC NUMBERS, UH, WHEN
ACCOUNTING FOR INFLATION THAT'S
JUST ONE REASON WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT S¼ B 969. ALLOWING CITIES
TO DESIGNATE OUTDOOR
ENTERTAINMENT ZONES WHERE BRICK
AND MORTAR ESTABLISHMENTS CAN
SELL. TAKE OUT ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES GIVES THESE BUSINESSES
AND THEIR BUSINESS DISTRICTS A
FIGHTING CHANCE AGAINST YEARS OF
PANDEMIC STRUGGLES. THIS BILL
REMOVES BARRIERS THAT HAVE
PREVIOUSLY PREVENTED THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS FROM FULLY
PARTICIPATING IN NEARBY OUTDOOR
SPECIAL EVENTS. CURRENTLY THESE
TYPES OF OUTDOOR EVENTS UTILIZE
A THIRD PARTY VENDOR FOR ALCOHOL
SALES DIRECTLY COMPETING WITH
NEARBY BUSINESSES. BY EXTENDING
THE AREAS WHERE PATRONS CAN
ENJOY BEVERAGES SOLD BY BRICK
AND MORTAR SHOPS. S¼ B 969 OPENS
UP NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR THESE
BUSINESSES TO GENERATE REVENUE
AND ATTRACT FOOT TRAFFIC. THIS
COULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
WAY SAN JOSE ENGAGES IN PUBLIC
EVENTS SUCH AS THE UPCOMING
SUPER BOWL, 60, COPA AMERICA AND
THE WORLD CUP. THIS NEW MODEL
WILL ENSURE THAT VISITORS ARE
SPENDING UH STAYS, UH, STAYS IN
THE LOCAL ECONOMY. FURTHERMORE
THE FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED BY S¼ B
969 ALLOWS CITIES TO TAILOR HOW
THEIR ENTERTAINMENT ZONES
OPERATE TO THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS.
THE LEGISLATION BUILDS IN
SAFEGUARDS AND CHECKPOINTS TO
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITY CONCERNS
ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. WORKING
WITH THE SAN JOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENT, COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, MAYOR AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS. WE WILL ENSURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS A GOOD FIT FOR
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITY. IN
SUMMARY, S¼ B 969 REPRESENTS A
PROACTIVE AND INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESSES, REVITALIZING
DOWNTOWN AREAS AND CREATING
ENGAGING EXPERIENCES FOR
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE ON S¼ B 969. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING.
RIGHT? GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS BOB SIMPSON.
I OWN AND OPERATE SEVERAL
NIGHTCLUBS AND RESTAURANTS AND
BARS IN SACRAMENTO. UH,
CURRENTLY I HAVE FOUR. I UH,
ALSO SIT ON THE BOARD OF CAL
KNIGHTS. IT'S AN ADVOCACY GROUP
FOR THE SOCIAL ECONOMY. I
STRONGLY BELIEVE S¼ B 969 WILL
HELP BOOST THE AREAS AND ARE
STRUGGLING STATEWIDE DOWNTOWNS
THAT HAVE LOST BUSINESSES DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. OUR DOWNTOWN
ENTERTAINMENT DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED NEGATIVELY WITH
REMOTE WORK. UH WHAT THE FIVE
O'CLOCK BUSINESS CROWD THAT USED
TO PACK MY BARS IS NÓ LONGER IN
OUR DOWNTOWNS AND S¼ B 969 WILL
ALLOW US TO CREATE LARGER
ACTIVATIONS BY PARTNERING
TOGETHER AS BUSINESSES, THROWING
FESTIVALS, BLOCK PARTIES AND
SPECIAL EVENTS. WE'RE ALL
SHARING THE SAME COST AND
SHARING THE SAME PROMOTIONAL. UH
OPPORTUNITIES. I BELIEVE CITIES
WILL SEE THE BENEFIT OF THAT
WITH INCREASED EMPLOYMENT AND
TAXATION. UH, OPERATORS ARE
STILL GONNA BE REGULATED BY A B
èC AND CITY JURISDICTIONS. AND
I BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD BE
FANTASTIC FOR THE SOCIAL ECONOMY
. SO PLEASE PASS S¼ B 969. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. UH, ANYONE ELSE HERE
IN SUPPORT? REMIND HER NOW TO
STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIR MEMBERS, JASON BRYANT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS
WERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR MEMBERS, KAREN L ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT AND
SPONSORSHIP THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBER SYLVIA
SOLI SHAW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MR CHAIR MEMBERS, CHRIS WALKER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OK AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS. FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS, WHICH HAS LED BY
PASTORS AND ECCLESIASTICAL
LEADERS THAT DEAL WITH ALCOHOL
AMONG THEIR CONGREGANTS AND THE
IMPACTS. ON A REGULAR BASIS. UM
I KEEP HEARING THAT ONE OF THE
PRIMARY JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THIS
BILL IS TO PUT BRICK AND MORTARS
ON A LEVEL PLAYING FILLED WITH
FESTIVALS OUT OF TOWN. PROVIDERS
AND VENDORS. IF THAT WERE THE
CASE, WE COULD LIMIT THE BILL TO
FESTIVALS AND OTHER ONE TIME
PERMITS. BUT IT'S THE AUTHOR
JUST ACKNOWLEDGED THIS WOULD
ALLOW THREE 165 DAYS OUT OF THE
YEAR. OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
TRANS FORM THEIR DOWNTOWN
BUSINESS AREAS INTO BOURBON
STREET. ARE YOU REALLY PREPARED
TO LET THAT GO STATEWIDE
THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES? OUR LOCAL LAW
OFFICIALS PREPARED FOR THAT. IS
THE STATE A B èC PREPARED FOR
THAT. I DON'T THINK SO. I THINK
THEY'RE ALL UNDER STAFF AND
OVERWORKED ALREADY. YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A PILOT
PROGRAM. IN REAL TIME BEFORE YOU
AUTHORIZE THIS STATEWIDE. IN SAN
FRANCISCO. THE BILL JUST PASSED
LAST YEAR. LET THAT PLAY OUT.
THE CITY HASN'T EVEN ADOPTED A
RESOLUTION TO AUTHORIZE S¼ B 76
IN SAN FRANCISCO YET LET'S SEE
HOW THAT GOES THERE. BEFORE YOU
EXPAND IT. STATEWIDE. 365 DAYS
OUT OF THE YEAR. SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THIS BILL
BE HELD AND LET'S SEE HOW THINGS
GO IN SAN FRANCISCO FIRST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? POLICE BOARD. IS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
DODD. THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
AGAIN. CARSON BENOWITZ
FREDERICKS. STILL THE RESEARCH
DIRECTOR OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE, UH,
WE ARE A NONPROFIT IN CENTER
FELL THAT PROMOTES EVIDENCE
BASED POLICIES TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE WOULD LIKE
TO URGE YOUR NÓ VOTE ON S¼ B
969. UM AGAIN. WE'VE I'VE
DISCUSSED THE RISE IN JUST EIGHT
YEARS. THE 75% RISE IN THE RATE
OF ALCOHOL AND MORTALITY. WE'VE
GONE FROM 11,000 OR SO IN 2016
TO 19,000 IN 2021. UH THAT IS
FIVE YEARS. THAT'S GOOD. GOOD
JOB. MY MATH THERE ME, BUT, UM
THAT IS ALL EXACERBATED BY BILLS
THAT ARE MEANT TO ENCOURAGE MORE
PEOPLE TO DRINK MORE. TO TRAVEL
MORE TO DRINK AND TO COME AND
GATHER TIGHTLY WHILE INTOXICATED
. THESE ARE ALL REALLY WELL
IDENTIFIED RISK FACTORS FOR, UH,
ACUTE ALCOHOL HARMS FOR MOTOR
VEHICLE CRASHES, WHICH AGAIN
HAVE GONE UP IN 2019. I BELIEVE
THEY WERE 960 SOMETHING THEY'RE
NOW OVER 1300. AS OF THE LAST
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF TRAFFIC
SAFETY REPORT. SO THAT IS RISING
AGAIN, UH, KIND OF OUT OF
CONTROL RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE A
BILL. IT'S GONNA BRING PEOPLE
INTO CITY CENTERS FROM WHEREVER
THEY ARE. THEY WILL DRIVE. UH
THEY WILL PARK THEIR CAR. THEY
WILL WALK AROUND THE STREET
DRINKING. SOME OF THEM WILL
DRINK TOO MUCH. SOME OF THEM WHO
HAVE NOT GOTTEN IN THEIR CAR
WILL HAVE DRUNK TOO MUCH. THEN
THE ONES WHO HAVE DRUNK TOO MUCH
WILL GET IN THEIR CAR DRIVE DOWN
THE STREETS THAT NOTHING IN THIS
BILL EXPECTS TO BE CLOSED. WITH
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE DRUNK TOO
MUCH ARE STILL ON THE STREET.
YOU BASICALLY, UH THE ONLY THING
THAT COULD MAKE THIS MORE OF A
PERFECT MACHINE TO FLATTEN
PEDESTRIANS IS TO INCREASE THE
AT LAST CALL TIME IN THESE
ZONES, SO THIS IS ALREADY REALLY
RISKY. THIS IS JUST A SPECIFIC
CASE, BUT WE ACTUALLY DO SEE
AGAIN IN BOURBON STREET. WE SEE,
UH, LOTS OF VIOLENCE ASSOCIATED
WITH IT. LOTS OF ATTEMPTS BY
RESIDENTS TO ROLL IT BACK. UM,
WE DO KNOW THAT RIGHT? WE HAVE
THE SORT OF SIGNATURE UH,
HORRIFYING ACT OF VIOLENCE
AROUND A STREET PARTY IN SAN
FRANCISCO WAS THE CASTRO STREET
HALLOWEEN. UH, UH, 20 YEARS AGO.
UM THE PROBLEM IS, IF YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT BOURBON STREET,
WHICH PRESUMABLY WOULD BE THE
IDEAL FOR MANY CITIES OF WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE YOU SEE?
SURE ENOUGH. A MASS SHOOTING ON
HALLOWEEN. YOU ALSO HAVE ONE ON
CHRISTMAS EVE AND YOU HAD JUST
HAD ONE ON MARDI GRAS. UM THIS
IS JUST THE ONES THAT I FOUND BY
SEARCHING FOR SHOOTINGS. UH, IN
THE FRENCH QUARTER ON SPECIAL
EVENTS. THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
ONES THAT HAPPEN EVERY DAY, AND
SO WE ARE REALLY RAISING THE
RISK OF THIS HAPPENING IN ANY
CITY THAT GOES FULL BORE FOR IT
SO SURE THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO
FULL BORE FOR IT. BUT THE THING
THAT WOULD PROTECT PEOPLE'S
LIVES IS TO MAKE IT SO THEY
CAN'T GO FULL BORE FOR IT. WE'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO LET PEOPLE KILL
THE RESIDENTS AND KILL THEIR
VISITORS. IF THEY WANT. WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO PREVENT THEM FROM
DOING IT. THAT IS SORT OF WHAT
ALCOHOL LAW IS ABOUT. AND I
BELIEVE THAT S¼ B 969 REALLY
LOOKS AT A WHOLE LOT OF
DEMONSTRATED HARMS FROM KIND OF
THIS. THIS, UH, REALLY
UNCONTROLLED AND UNACCOUNTABLE,
UM SORRY. I'M GONNA TRY TO WRAP
THIS UP. BUT I JUST WANNA
EMPHASIZE UNACCOUNTABLE BARS
CANNOT USE RESPONSIBLE BEVERAGE
SERVICE WITH THEIR PATRONS WHEN
THOSE PATRONS ARE NOT IN THE
BARS, OK, SO UNACCOUNTABLE. I'LL
CALL SALES WILL RAMP THIS OUT OF
CONTROL. AND I REALLY HOPE THAT
THIS WOULD MAKE YOU SEE THAT A
NÓ VOTE ON S¼ B 969 IS THE WAY
TO GO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
THAT'S RIGHT. YES. THANK YOU. UH
THEN AGAIN, UH, THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. MY NAME IS RAUL VERDUGO.
SO UH, TECHNICALLY, TO BE FAIR,
I'M ONLY SUPPOSED TO ALLOW YOU
TO STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT? THAT'S FINE. I DON'T
WANT TO GO TOO LONG ANYWAY, BUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT, UH, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO S¼ B 969 THE
ENTERTAINMENT SLASH PARTY ZONE
BILL, BECAUSE, UM BY TAKING
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION OUT OF BARS
WHERE STAFF ARE TRAINED IN
RESPON BEDFORD SERVICE, THERE
WERE NÓ LONGER BE SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE THE ALCOHOL SOLD WILL NOT
BE CONSUMED BY UNDERAGE YOUTH.
IN ADDITION, WE ALSO FIND
PROBLEMS WITH S¼ B 969 BECAUSE
IT'S SUCCESS HINGES ENTIRELY
UPON WHETHER IT GETS MORE PEOPLE
TO DRINK MORE ALCOHOL. I SAID,
STATE, YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR NOT SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THAT MUST BE ON ME BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE ROLLING
HERE THIS MORNING, SO I'M GONNA
BRING IT BACK TO, UH, THE
COMMITTEE. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS? OK, SENATOR SEYARTO.
JUST TO CLARIFY PEOPLE CAN STILL
HAVE THEIR STREET FESTIVALS
WHERE THEY HAVE THEIR TEMPORARY
USE PERMITS FOR ALCOHOL. PEOPLE
ARE SELLING IT ON THE STREET.
AND YOU HAVE MAYBE A RESTAURANT
THAT IS BEHIND, YOU KNOW, IN ONE
OF THE, UH, SHOPPING CENTERS
THAT ARE THAT LINE, THE STREET
THAT'S NOW CLOSED SO YOU CAN
WALK AROUND SO PEOPLE ARE
DRINKING THERE. UM IF THEY WANT.
LINES TOO LONG OR SOMETHING.
THEY JUST GO OVER THERE INSTEAD
OF WAITING IN LINE AND IN ORDER,
SOMETHING FROM THE RESTAURANT.
WHERE THEY COULD PROBABLY ORDER
IN ANYWAY. THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
IS THEY CAN TAKE THAT OUTSIDE
AND JOIN THE STREET FESTIVAL.
WHILE THE FESTIVAL IS GOING ON,
IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE A LOCAL AREA
, A LOCAL ENTITY FROM CREATING
MORE RULES. THAT ARE RESTRICTIVE
IF THEY'RE HAVING PROBLEMS. LIKE
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE BECAUSE MY
THING IS, PEOPLE ARE GONNA GO.
RIGHT THEY'RE GONNA GO TO THIS
FESTIVAL, AND IF THEY'RE
INCLINED TO DRINK, THEY'LL DRINK
UM, IF THEY'RE NOT, THEY WON'T
UM THEY'RE GONNA GET ALCOHOL AND
HOPEFULLY NOT OVER IMBIBE. SOME
PEOPLE WILL BUT IT DOESN'T THIS
BILL DOESN'T ADD TO THAT AMOUNT
OR SUBTRACT TO THAT AMOUNT. ALL
IT DOES IS HELP THOSE
RESTAURANTS THAT EVERY TIME
THERE'S A FESTIVAL RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM SURVIVE BECAUSE
THEY'LL BE IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
ZONE ALSO, UM, IS THAT CORRECT?
THAT IS CORRECT. UM AND IT ALSO
DOES REQUIRE IN THE IMPLEMENTING
ORDINANCE THAT THE CITY PASSES.
UH UM MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS CHECKING TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE OVER 21 AND ALSO
CONSULTATION WITH THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT. UM IT ALSO
DOES ALLOW CITIES TO MOVE AWAY
FROM DOING IT JUST FOR SPECIAL
EVENTS. AND IF THEY WANNA SAY
EVERY SATURDAY, THIS AREA IS
GOING THEY CAN DO THAT WITHOUT
HAVING TO TIE IT TO A SPECIFIC
SPECIAL EVENT. UM BUT THAT'S
THEIR LOCAL FLEXIBILITY. THAT'S
THEY DETERMINE THAT THEY
DETERMINE THAT THIS DOESN'T
FORCE THEM TO DO THAT. CAN
IGNORE THIS ENTIRELY. AND IT HAS
NÓ APPLICATION. THANK YOU.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR, I. I APPRECIATE THE LOCAL
CONTROL ASPECT OF IT. THAT'S HOW
IT'S BEEN VERY IMPORTANT FOR ME,
AND I'M SURE FOR MANY OTHERS
THAT HAVE BEEN ELECTED OFFICIALS
LOCALLY. UH WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
IN AND LIKE I SAID, I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE MORE SAFEGUARDS IN THE
BILL THAT YOU PASSED LAST YEAR.
AS AS YOU STATED, I WANNA SEE IF
YOU CAN EXPLAIN A LITTLE FURTHER
YOU I THINK I HEARD YOU SAY IT'S
REGULATED BY A B, èC AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY CAN AND CANNOT DO. UM CAN
YOU GO FURTHER INTO IT IN TERMS
OF SAFEGUARDS? WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN? UH, SO THE CITY HAS TO
COME UP WITH SOME UM, STANDARDS
OR A B èC. CAN YOU JUST TALK A
LITTLE FURTHER ON THAT? SO UM SO
THE, UH, AGAIN THE RIGHT NOW A
CITY CAN ALREADY DO AN ASPECT OF
THIS BY HAVING OUTSIDE VENDORS
COME IN TO CITIES CAN DO THAT
TODAY AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THAT FOR A VERY LONG TIME. THEY
CAN SAY THIS AREA IS AN OPEN
OPEN CONTAINER ZONE. PEOPLE CAN
WALK AROUND WITH WITH ALCOHOL
AND OPEN CONTAINER. UM WE'RE
GONNA BRING OUTSIDE VENDORS IN
TO SELL. SO THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING TODAY. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS TO PARTICIPATE THE
SAME AS THE OUTSIDE VENDORS, AND
IT ALLOWS THE CITY TO DO IT IN A
WAY THAT IT'S NOT JUST TIED TO A
SPECIAL EVENT, BUT THEY CAN SAY
WE'RE GONNA DO IT ON WEEKENDS OR
SATURDAYS OR THREE NIGHT, YOU
KNOW, THREE DAYS A MONTH OR
WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE, UH TO DO,
UM, WE PUT VARIOUS GUARD RAILS
IN IN THE ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR,
WHICH WE HAVE STUCK WITH, UM,
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE OVER 21, MAKING SURE THAT
THE OPEN CONTAINER ZONE CANNOT
REMAIN OPEN PAST THE LAST, UM,
HOUR WHENEVER THE LATEST SERVICE
HOUR IS ON THE LOCAL LIQUOR
LICENSES, SO IF THEY'RE ALL IF
ALL THE LOCAL LIQUOR LICENSES
HAVE THEY ALL HAVE TO STOP
SELLING AT MIDNIGHT. THE OPEN
THE ENTERTAINMENT ZONE HAS TO
SHUT DOWN BY MIDNIGHT, FOR
EXAMPLE, UM AND THEN, LIKE THE
REQUIREMENT TO CONSULT WITH
LOCAL POLICE ON TO GET FEEDBACK
ON, UH ON, UH UH, PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES. UM MAYBE THEY ALSO HAVE
TO PROVIDE ALL THE DOCUMENTATION
UH TO A B èC THEY HAVE TO
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO REVIEW UH,
AN AUDIT. BASICALLY THE
ENTERTAINMENT IS ON EVERY TWO
YEARS TO DETERMINE IF THERE ARE
ANY ISSUES AND THEN MAKE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO A B
èC. AND THEN, OF COURSE, IF YOU
HAVE LICENSE HOLDERS ARE
VIOLATING THEIR LICENSE OR
CAUSING PROBLEMS THE YOU KNOW
THE A B èC CAN ALWAYS TAKE
ACTION. SO IT'S VERY SPECIFIC.
THAT'S A THIRD PARTY VENDOR.
THAT'S ALREADY AN ESTABLISHED,
UM INDUSTRY THAT SELLS ALCOHOL,
SO LET ME SHARE WITH YOU WHERE
MY THOUGHTS ARE GOING RIGHT NOW.
I THINK IT WAS, UH, LAST YEAR
WHERE WE PASSED THE FOOD VENDOR
BILL, WHICH YOU KNOW, WE ALL
WANTED TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
STREET VENDORS, RIGHT? AND UH,
IF YOU KNOW, AS I DRIVE AROUND L
A COUNTY NOW, UM IT WAS MEANT TO
HELP LIKE, YOU KNOW, SMALL.
PEOPLE AND NOW PEOPLE ARE TAKING
OUT FULL KITCHENS AND INDUSTRIAL
SIZE. UH, YOU KNOW, COOKWARE,
AND IT'S BECOME SORT OF AN
OUTSIDE RESTAURANT. BUT YOU HAVE
A SAFEGUARD WHERE YOU'RE STILL
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
LICENSE THEY HAVE OTHER YOU KNOW
, THERE'S WAYS OF CURBING THAT
KIND OF OUTSIDE CELL WITH
INDIVIDUALS. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL DOESN'T EXPAND WHAT
THE OUTSIDE VENDORS CAN DO
BECAUSE THOSE OUTSIDE VENDORS
ARE ABLE TO OPERATE NOW, IF A
CITY CHOOSES WHAT THE BUT THIS
BILL DOES IN ADDITION TO
ALLOWING TO GO BEYOND THE
SPECIAL EVENTS TO A MORE REGULAR
BASIS, IF THE CITY WANTS TO IT
EMPOWERS THE BRICK AND MORTAR
BARS AND RESTAURANTS TO WHICH
THEY ARE BARRED. UNDER STATE LAW
FIRM PARTICIPATING NOW, SO IT'S
THE BRICK AND MORTAR BARS AND
RESTAURANTS THAT ARE THEN WOULD
BE THE NEW PARTICIPANTS. AND
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY THE LOCAL
GENERALLY MOM AND POP
ESTABLISHMENTS. AND THAT'S THE
GOAL BECAUSE I SEE ON THIS OTHER
SIDE WHERE THEY'RE NOT NÓ LONGER
GOING TO RESTAURANTS. THEY'RE
GOING OUTSIDE, BUT I'M TRYING TO
FIND THAT MIDDLE GROUND, BUT I
MEAN, I AGREE. I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HELP. UH, THOSE, UH, BRICK AND
MORTARS THAT ARE NOT DOING WELL.
SO I JUST YOU KNOW, WANTED TO
CLARIFY THESE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THAT'S YEAH. UH, G
SENATOR OPPOSITION MENTIONED
DOING THIS THREE 165 DAYS A YEAR
IN HIS, UH, I. I UNDER THE
IMPRESSION IT'S ONLY AT SPECIAL
EVENTS OR PERHAPS THE WEEKEND.
YOU CLARIFY THAT IT'S NOT JUST
SPECIAL EVENTS. CITIES WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO IT ON A
REGULAR BASIS IF THEY WANT TO.
UM I AM, UH, DOUBTFUL THAT ANY
CITY IS GOING TO CHOOSE TO DO IT
THREE 165 DAYS A YEAR. UM, BUT
CITIES WILL CHOOSE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO DO IT ONCE A MONTH. COME
ON. SO A WEEK BEFORE WEEKEND.
THURSDAY THROUGH SUNDAY. THEY
CAN DO IT. UH, THEY THAT'LL BE A
LOCAL, UH, CHOICE AND I'LL HAVE
TO BE DONE WITH WITHIN ALL THE
CONSTRAINTS AND THEY'RE STILL
ALL THEY STILL ALL HAVE LIQUOR
LICENSES ON THEIR A B èC, WHICH
IF THEY VIOLATE THEY CAN BE
PENALIZED OR REVOKED. THANK YOU.
HM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UH, MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU, SENATOR. I
UH, SUPPORT, UH, WHERE YOU'RE
MOVING WITH IT? UH, JUST TO
COMMENT IN THAT, UH THE DRAFT
LANGUAGE GIVES PRETTY CLEAR
DEFINITION TO ENTERTAINMENT ZONE
AND IN THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
CODE LAYS OUT THE RIGHTS OF THE
VENDORS. UH, IF THEY ARE WITHIN
AN ENTERTAINMENT ZONE, I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT PERHAPS THE
LANGUAGE COULD BE STRENGTHENED
AT YOU KNOW, TO BE VERY CLEAR,
UH, THAT THE CREATION OF SUCH A
OWN PER S¼ E IS EXCLUSIVE TO THE
LOCAL LAND USE AUTHORITY WITHIN
THE PARAMETERS. I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S EXPLICITLY MADE AS
CLEAR AS IT COULD BE IN THE
DRAFT LANGUAGE AND COULD LEAD TO
OTHER UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
UH, FOR EXAMPLE, IN PUTTING
INORDINATE PRESSURE ON A LOCAL
LAND USE AUTHORITY TO CREATE
SUCH A ZONE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO UH, I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
OUT OF COMMITTEE. BUT I DO THINK
THAT LANGUAGE, MAKING IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT AN
OBLIGATION OF THE LOCAL LAND USE
AUTHORITY THAT THIS CREATION OF
THIS ZONE LIES EXCLUSIVELY AND
SOLELY WITH THE LOCAL LAND USE
AUTHORITY AND THAT THEY'RE UNDER
NÓ OBLIGATION TO CREATE SUCH A
ZONE IN THE FIRST PLACE. OK SO I
JUST THINK I THINK THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE MADE MORE CLEAR IN
THE DRAFT, BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. I
APPRECIATE IT. WE'LL GO BACK AND
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. LANGUAGE
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY I. I THINK IT
SAYS THAT AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
AN INTENT. BUT IF IT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED, WE HAVE NÓ PROBLEM
DOING THAT. SENATOR W. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR, SENATOR. I AGREE
WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS. MY
COLLEAGUE HAS MADE ONE OTHER
THING. SO JUST SOME SOME IDEAS
AS YOU'RE GOING BACK IS ONE IS
WHAT UM SENATOR ARCHULETA
MENTIONED IS IT COULD BE THREE
165 DAYS BECAUSE THERE ARE AREAS
IN MY DISTRICT THERE'S TIMES
WHERE WE HAVE FESTIVALS FOR
THREE MONTHS. AND SO I DON'T
WANT IT TO BE A BURDEN ON THE
RESIDENTS AS WELL. AND SO I
THINK IF THERE IS A THERE'S SOME
KIND OF GUIDELINES THAT WE CAN
ALLOW CITIES OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO KNOW THAT THEY CAN'T JUST
BLANKET THE ENTIRE CITY AS AN
ENTERTAINMENT ZONE. UM, BECAUSE
BACK THEN WHEN WE HAD, UM UM
OTHER ZONES ALLOW SOME CITIES
HAVE USED IT AND JUST MADE IT
THE ENTIRE CITY. AND SO I THINK
THAT IF THERE'S SOME KIND OF
GUIDELINES OR RESTRICTION TO NOT
ALLOW CITIES OR COUNTY TO
COMPLETELY ZONE THEIR ENTIRE
CITY AS ENTERTAINMENT ZONE,
CAUSING BURDENS TO THE RESIDENTS
, I THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
OR SOME KIND OF APPEAL PROCESS
FOR RESIDENTS, NOT JUST TO CITY
COUNCIL BUT ALSO TO A B èC. UM
AND THEN THE OTHER PART IS, YOU
KNOW IS THERE ANY TIMES OR DATE?
RESTRICTIONS IN THESE
ENTERTAINMENT. ARE WE ALLOWING
THEM TO GO? 24 HOURS A DAY? UM
OR IS THIS JUST CLEARLY WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL DECIDE? SO
THERE ARE THREE. FIRST OF ALL,
THIS DOESN'T YEAH. II I THINK WE
JUST NEED TO MAKE IT MAKE IT
CLEAR HERE. THEY CAN GO 365 DAYS
OUT OF THE YEAR. RIGHT NOW A
CITY CAN IN LOCAL CONTROL. THIS
JUST ALLOWS IF THEY'RE DOING
THAT THOSE SPECIFIED BARS TO BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. CORRECT ME.
IF I'M WRONG, I MEAN, THEY THEY
COULD DO SPECIAL EVENTS 365. NOW
IF IT'S MORE, IT'S CLUNKIER TO
DO IT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO KEEP
PULLING PERMITS, BUT THEY COULD
DO THAT. UM AND, UM, AND TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, NÓ. THIS
DOES NOT EXTEND OUR I MEAN, AS
YOU KNOW, I'VE I'VE CARRIED THE
4 A.M. BELL BEFORE IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAS THE SENATE HAS
BEEN VERY HOSPITABLE, UH, TO
THAT BILL, THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR A
LITTLE LESS SO, AND GOVERNOR
BROWN A LITTLE LESS SO, UM, SO
YOU KNOW WHERE MY VIEW IS ON
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THE HOURS SO WAY IS STILL THE
END TIME. IN ADDITION, IT DOES
NOT EXTEND THE HOURS FOR A
SPECIFIC PERMITS BECAUSE THERE
ARE CITIES WHERE EVERYTHING ENDS
AT MIDNIGHT OR AT 10 P.M.
BECAUSE THE CITY IS A MATTER OF
LAND USE HAS MADE THAT DECISION.
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE THAT UNLESS
THE CITY DECIDES TO CHANGE IT.
IN ADDITION, IF A BAR UM IF A B
èC HAS SAID YOU CAN'T YOU CAN
ONLY SERVE UNTIL 8 P.M. OR 10,
P.M. OR MIDNIGHT. THAT
RESTRICTION FROM A B èC WILL
CONTINUE IN THE CITY CAN'T
CHANGE THAT, SO ALL OF THE TIME
LIMITATIONS RETAIN, REMAIN WERE
NOT CHANGING THAT AT ALL. MOVE
THE BILL. SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
RIGHT, SENATOR WEINER. I JUST
WANTED CLARIFICATION OF YOUR
BILL. SO UM, CURRENTLY IF THERE
IS AN ENTERTAINMENT ZONE OR A
FESTIVAL, UM OUTSIDE VENDORS CAN
SELL, UM, ALCOHOL, BUT THE
RESTAURANTS, BRICK AND MORTAR
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE. UM CANNOT
CORRECT. UM SO WITH YOUR BILL
THAT WOULD CHANGE THAT. NOW MY
QUESTION IS REALLY ABOUT HOW TO
REGULATE THE ACCESS OF, UH,
MINORS OR UNDER 21. SO WOULD
THAT MEAN THAT IF THE RESTAURANT
PARTICIPATES, THEY COULD NÓ
LONGER. WELCOME PATRONS UNDER
AGE 21, OR WOULD THEY HAVE TO
PUT IT PUT IN? UM SOME TYPE OF,
UH, RESTRICTIONS TO ENSURE LIKE
ONE OF THOSE BANS OR CHECKING? I
Dð S¼ LIKE HOW WOULD IT CHANGE
OR HOW WOULD IT STAY THE SAME.
THIS WOULDN'T CHANGE WHO CAN
ENTER AN ESTABLISHMENT SO RIGHT
NOW UNDER 21 CAN UNDER A
RESTAURANT BUT CANNOT ENTER A
BAR THAT WILL REMAIN THE SAME.
UM WHEN AN AMENDMENT THAT WE ARE
KEEPING FROM THE ASSEMBLY LAST
YEAR IS THAT THE CITY WHEN IT
ADOPTS AN ORDINANCE HAS TO
PROVIDE FOR HOW, UM THEY'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT IT'S 21 AND
OLDER AND THEY COULD DO IT WITH
WITH WRISTBANDS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THEY COULD. THEY'RE PROBABLY
VARIOUS WAYS THAT THEY CAN DO
IT. UH, BUT THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION. SENATOR
GLASER. SECRETARY UH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CAN I? OH, EXCUSE ME.
WOULD YOU LIKE A BRIEF HERE AND
I? I DON'T. I'M NOT GONNA CLOSE.
I DO WANT TO ADDRESS ONE THING,
I. I RESPECT YOU KNOW, I KNOW IN
THIS COMMITTEE, THERE'S A LOT OF
DEBATE ABOUT THE PROS AND CONS
OF ALCOHOL AS SOMEONE WHO'S AND
I'VE SAID THIS PUBLICLY BEFORE.
WHO LOST A CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER
TO A DUI. I'M EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE TO THOSE ISSUES. UH,
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT CITY
ABILITIES TO HAVE A VIBRANCY IN
THEIR DOWNTOWN. I DO WANT TO
MENTION ONE THING. THERE WAS AN
INACCURACY NOT JUST ABOUT MY
CITY, BUT ABOUT MY NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT I'VE LIVED IN FOR ALMOST 25
OR 27. YEARS ABOUT THE CASTRO
HALLOWEEN, UH, AS SOMEONE WHO
LIVES IN THE CASTRO, WHO WAS
PRESENT AT THAT HALLOWEEN WHEN
THERE WAS A TRAGICALLY A
SHOOTING, AND THAT RESULTED IN
HALLOWEEN BEING SH DOWN IN THE
CASTRO THAT WAS A GANG SHOOTING.
IT WAS NOT AN ALCOHOL RELATED
SHOOTING. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT, UH, TO BE ACCURATE
WHEN WE SAY THESE KINDS OF
THINGS. THANK YOU. AND I ASKED
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WE HAVE THAT MOTION.
UH, CAN WE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. S¼ P 969 MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS GOD HERE.
EXCUSE ME. SUCH IN A HURRY. AYE
DODD. I WILL PRESENT MEAN I WILL
I. ALVARADO GILL. HØI ALVARADO.
GAIL I ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. I
ASHBY BRADFORD GLASER. GLAZER. I
JONES JONES. I WIN. WHAT WAS
THAT, AND I Ó B¢O. OCHO B, I
PAD PAD. I PENTIN TINO I. ROTH.
RUBIO RUBIO, I CEO SEO I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. I PULLED IT OPEN.
THERE'S THREE HOW MANY OK, THAT
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES, BUT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL.
EVERYONE. WILL START START OUT
WITH, UH UH, THE CONSENT ITEMS.
THAT OPEN THE ROLL, PLEASE.
ABSENT MEMBERS, ASHBY BRADFORD.
BLAZER. GLAZER. I ROSS. SORRY.
YES. WHO ELSE IS IN HERE? ME?
BROTH AND BRADFORD. OK WE'LL GO
NOW TO AS EVERYBODY THAT'S HERE.
VOTED ON 969 WEINER. YES. OK, SO
WE'LL NOW GO TO, UH, SB 1028
ALVARADO GIL. TO OPEN THE MHM.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ABSENT MEMBERS
ASHBY BRADFORD, IT'S ONE OF
THOSE LASER EYE ROTH. WE HAVE
JUST BROUGHT. OK, UM YOU WANNA
GET CAN WE SEE IF I THIS. RUBIO
IS ON COMMITMENT. YOU'RE DONE.
YOU'RE DONE. YOU'RE DONE. GATES,
ALL RIGHT? SO IS SENATOR ROTH IN
A POSITION WHERE HE HE'S ON HIS
WAY. SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THIS UP
AND JUST MOMENTARILY. WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR YOU. BUT WE
STILL HERE FOR 20 MINUTES. RIGHT
THERE. WE JUST GIVE THEM OUT.
YOU WANT ME TO FIND HIM? JUST
GET YOU OUT. LET'S LET'S OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE CONSENT ITEMS.
ASHBY. HØI ASH B. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I THAT'S 15. HOW STILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR SENATOR
ROTH. WERE MOVED TO BUY ITEM
NUMBER THREE S¼ B 969 WIENER,
OPEN THE ROLL POLICE. ASHBY
ASHBY, I, BRADFORD BRADFORD. I
NOW MOVE TO SORRY ABOUT THAT.
KEEP THAT OPEN. NOW WE'LL MOVE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR S¼ B
1028. OPEN THE ROLE, PLEASE.
ASHBY. HÌ B. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
I ROSS. RIGHT? SORRY. I WAS NOT
THERE. DO SO.
MADE YOU CALL YOU CALL ME YOU
CALL ME AND I SAY HERE. IT'S
BEEN ONE OF THOSE MORNINGS.
HELLO, HØI. THE ROLE. ON THE
CONSENT ITEMS. CALL THE ROLL,
ROTH. I 16 0. 00 SENATOR,
SENATOR YEAH, TWO. THERE'S TWO
MORE SO HOW? HOW HOW MANY VOTES
16 0 ON THE 16 0 ON THE
CONSECUTIVE THAT'S OUT. WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THREE S¼ B
969 WIENER. OPEN THE ROLL,
PLEASE. ROUGH ROTH. I 16 0 16 0.
THAT BILL WAS OUT. WE MOVE NOW
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR S¼ B 1028
ALVARADO GILL, PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. ROTH. I 16 0 16 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT THAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK STAFF AND
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM FOR
HELPING OUT TODAY THIS MEETING
WAS ADJOURNED. YEAH. I.
THANK YOU GUYS. UH, SO UH, I
THINK YOU'RE LEAVING YOUR PHONE
HERE, PHILIPPE. THANK YOU. KEEP
IT. ENT. LIKE THAT. HOW YOU
CHANGE YOUR ONE. TAKE CARE.
THANK YOU. I GRAB MY PHONE. YES.
I SO YEAH. DOWNLOADED A
ENTERTAINMENT. FOR HIS